Musik
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
ja bei windows weißt du nie ob das noch tut was schon bei ich habe battlefield 6 aber ich
habe battlefield 6 und nicht installiert oder gespielt ich habe es aber ich bin dumm ich weiß
aber ich habe es gekauft
zu machen aber bald kann ich spielen weil bald habe ich eine windows kiste
mit windows 25 windows 11 25 hat zwei vollverschlüssel und secure boot an
das problem nämlich heute ausprobieren ich habe es nämlich wie angekündigt
gemacht ich werde mein windows problem mit geld erschlagen und hat man einfach
eine neue ssd gekauft da kann ich parallel einfach jetzt mein
altes und neues meine neue installation benutzen ich ziehe mir dann alles rüber
ich meine ich habe backup auf einer externen platte aber so ist mir lieber
das top aktuell ja ich ziehe alles rüber was ich brauche und habe dann noch ein
backup system was ich bieten kann falls das neue irgendwie probleme macht so
selbst ein eis dankeschön für den sap 39 jahre
ja und was ich jetzt ausprobieren muss ist ob windows 25 hat zwei funktioniert
Ja, 39 Jahre steht doch da.
Ob das funktioniert mit Secure Boot, Veracrypt und vor allem mit lokalem User Account.
Lokaler User Account ist das Wichtigste.
Weil ich werde garantiert, also ohne Scheiß, eins sage ich euch.
wenn Microsoft
wirklich
das alles
gesperrt hat oder
sperrt,
dann
benutze ich
Linux. Ich meine, ich produziere
jetzt schon Windows und Linux parallel,
ja, aber dann
scheiße ich wirklich auf
alle aktuellen Games
und werde
das, werde ich nur noch Linux benutzen.
es ist mir dann egal wenn es nicht mehr möglich ist lokalen user zu haben ich
sehe es nicht ein dass ich gezwungen werde einen microsoft account benutzen
zu müssen
lokaler user funktioniert wie immer da haben die nichts daran geändert doch die
haben dieses ganze ob zeug angeblich ausgeschaltet und 25 hat zwei
wir können es ja gleich mal ausprobieren
gibt es bei 6 für linux mehr wird auch nicht laufen wegen anti cheat
du brauchst bei windows pro das ob zeug nicht das probieren wir jetzt aus was
was muss ich denn was muss ich dann machen bei windows 11 pro muss ich muss
ich gucken dass ich keine netzwerkverbindung habe oder was muss
man was muss man machen mit domäne ja mit domäne will ich ja nicht die
einfachen lokalen user dass es mit ad geht es mir auch klar mit der
möglichkeit darf man sich trauen das aufzumachen oder wird man da gleich
gerollt oder irgendwie sowas
du musst es das netzwerk haben wir probieren das aus wenn nicht erstellen
wir ein USB-Stick mit Rufus oder so und da haben die ja irgendeine so eine unattended
XML oder sowas und dann funktioniert es angeblich.
Okay, short.
Ja, dann.
Ja, das ist Abfuck.
Okay, Feudei, das probiere ich gleich aus.
Huge.
Okay, weiter. Und was muss man jetzt machen?
Ja, das war doch früher so. Das funktioniert doch angeblich nicht mehr.
Das funktioniert doch angeblich nicht mehr.
Okay, wir probieren das aus
Windows 11 ISO Download
So
Ist das denn überhaupt 25H2 schon?
Woher weiß ich das denn jetzt?
Was er erklärt noch weiter
Aha
Ah ja, sag ich doch
So schlau bin ich auch, das hätten wir uns das Video sparen können.
Er hat uns gesagt, dass er nicht weiß, wie es bei dem neuesten Windows funktioniert.
Nice.
Wir probieren das aus.
Wir probieren das einmal aus, wie es früher ging.
spricht was gegen windows 11 iot ich habe keine ahnung was da der unterschied ist kein schimmer
ok also so windows 11 multi edition iso ich lade schon mal sie so runter wählen sie eine
sprache aus englisch englisch international was staat msc hx local only was 3000 varianten
okay das probieren wir aus und wo ist der download klopft jetzt chat bin ich dumm wo
ist der bus hier oben ist auch nicht dass die sehen konnte
ok das lädt jetzt noch ein bisschen runter wir benutzen wir benutzen weil
ich starte mein linux kiste wir benutzen hier wieder die secure boot kiste die
wir schon haben wobei wir benutzen nicht die secure
Ne, wir legen eine neue Kiste an.
Habe ich überhaupt Platz?
Habe ich Platz auf meiner Kiste?
Ja, okay, ich habe auch genug Platz.
Wir legen eine neue Windows-Kiste an mit Secure Boot und allem.
Ah, das dauert jetzt eh kurz.
Akustik-Koppler, ja, das passt hier heute nicht wirklich dazu.
Die Leute sind blöd, wenn sie sich unter Linux
beschweren
Dazu habe ich mal ein Video gemacht
Das sind die Leute, die abgefuckt
sind von Windows und eigentlich weiter
Windows wollen, nur ohne den Windows-Abfuck
Und wenn die dann bei Linux
landen, dann wird das nix
Wenn man sich unter Linux beschwert, dass man
eine Shell aufmachen muss, ist halt dumm
weil die Linux-Shell ist halt nice
und die Windows-Shell suckt, wobei man sagen muss
PowerShell ist eine
super sache für automatisierung aber nichts für für daily arbeiten war
natürlich dass natur rein raus machen die eine rgb beleuchtung nicht richtig
gesünd jetzt macht du machst du unter windows auto shell auf ich mache das
auch ab und zu aber unter windows ist es eklig wobei ich sagen muss immerhin
immerhin ist dieses neue terminal programm was sie da haben hier mit den
tabs und sowas das geht jetzt halbwegs also das kann man als terminal zu benutzen erinnert sich
erinnert sich noch einer an das alte cmd das alte cmd fenster das war wirklich der abgrund tiefe
bullshit also das alte cmd fenster ich weiß nicht dass wir kamen irgendwie direkt noch aus windows
3.11 oder sowas.
Konnte komplett knicken.
Das war grausam. Das konnte ich noch nicht mal richtig
resizen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Das gibt es nicht mehr, oder?
Was ist VCTL?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ach, VMW.
Das alte CMD-Fenster gibt es glaube ich nicht mehr.
Okay, ISO ist runtergeladen.
Dann, okay.
Heute kein Go, Leute.
Kein Go. Aber
Arch, by the way, wir machen mal kurz Package-Updates
Wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind
Zack, Ruby wird installiert, Leute
Und der Packet Tracer wird geab...
Packet Tracer 9 gibt's jetzt
Hui
Packet Tracer 9
Hier, neuster, neuster Shit von Cisco, Alter
Sieht immer noch ultra hässlich aus.
Gut, Packet Tracer war jetzt noch nie optisch die schönste Software, aber die war halt richtig nice.
Aber wir installieren das jetzt mal.
Oh.
Funktioniert ja richtig gut.
Ach, das war doch die Geschichte, wo man manuell runterladen muss und dann das ausführen, gell?
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ne, dann machen wir das jetzt nicht.
Ich mein, man muss immerhin sagen
Packet Tracer ist eigentlich recht funktional
Ne, schönes Programm ist es
Nicht
Bin ich nicht mehr eingeloggt, warum bin ich nicht mehr eingeloggt
Ich hab mich doch das letzte Mal eingeloggt
Och ne
Muss ich mir einen neuen Fake Account erstellen
Schau wieder
Die haben bestimmt meinen Account gelöscht
Kann das sein
Die haben erkannt, dass es ein Fake Account ist und haben den gelöscht
Deswegen bin ich nicht mehr eingeloggt.
So, jetzt haben wir alles geupdatet.
Gucken wir mal, ob die Jetbrains Dinger noch ein Update haben.
Oh, guck mal hier.
Pycharm gibt es ein neues.
Golem ist mir zu anstrengend, die Playlist hier gerade.
Wartet mal.
Ja, viel angenehmer.
Der wurde nicht gelöscht.
Mein fake account bei cisco wurde gelöscht mit dem der 10 minute
10 minute mail wie heißt das doch 10 minute mail oder
Ja ich bin zu einer fake adresse gemacht zum registrieren durch packet tracer oder laden kann
Jetzt so etwa ja einer der wenigen leute die nicht tatsächlich von youtube den ich tatsächlich sogar persönlich über den weg gelaufen
So update all
Dann warten wir mal, bis das Updatered.
So, wir können schon mal eine neue VM anlegen.
Meine VM hängt.
Was jetzt?
Also ich habe lange nicht mehr reingeguckt.
Der hatte ja zwei Channels früher.
Eines für Battlefield und eins für Warzone oder sowas war das glaube ich.
so custom workstation wir installieren später installieren windows leider windows 11 hack windows
ja darfst du da ruhig speichern ist okay muss muss ich das machen 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
ok das braucht man braucht man anscheinend secure boot machen wir an uefi secure boot
number of processes 1 number of course keine ahnung 8 bam und 16 gb dass er
windows chipt auch ordentlich läuft nut ja ja auch gut create new disk 64 gig single file
keck windows so edit wir schmeißen bloß noch den printer raus ansonsten können wir eigentlich alles
so lassen.
Der hat richtig krasses Aim, der
Äquador. Ja.
Der hat bestimmt auch schon
Cheat-Anschuldigungen und sowas, was alle Leute mit
ordentlichem Aim früher oder später
mal kriegen.
Gerade wenn man durch Zufall
mal in die gleiche Richtung guckt,
wo hinter der Wand jemand war oder so,
kommt gleich, ah, Wallhack!
Direkt.
Kommen die Leute, ich wusste schon immer, und dann werden
die Videos analysiert und sagen, ja,
bei Sekunde 37
einhalb hat er
eigentlich gesnappt auf den
Head und hätte ihn noch gar nicht sehen können.
Da wird das alles überanalysiert.
Aber das ist echt
gut, ey. Ist mir auch schon aufgefallen.
Also schon früher aufgefallen.
Jetzt in letzter Zeit habe ich nicht reingeguckt.
Rambo mit
den Plexi. Ja gut, bei manchen Leuten
ist es ja auch so auffällig und es kommen noch
ein paar äußere Sachen zusammen.
Hast du noch Kontakt
zum Commander Krieger? Ne.
Reboot.
Chat, während meine Linux-Kiste
rebooted und die Windows
vor allem erstellt wird, ich hab
heute beim Mittagessen,
also vor einer Stunde oder so,
hab ich ein bisschen Reddit gelesen
und da habe ich echt wieder gedacht,
die Rust-Leute
drehen echt am Rad.
Da gab es einen Thread auf,
nennt man das Thread überhaupt auf Reddit?
Ein Post auf Reddit.
Was ich machen will, ich will Windows 11 installieren,
25H2 und gucken, wie man das mit dem lokalen User macht.
Da war ich im Rust,
wobei, bevor ich es jetzt erzähle,
ich zeige es euch einfach mal.
Da musste ich mir echt wieder
an den Kopf greifen und habe mir gedacht,
Was ist mit den Rust-Leuten teilweise verkehrt?
Moment, Moment, Moment.
So, hier, Firefox auf.
Also, Rust.
Rust, Reddit, so.
Und nicht PlayRust, sondern die Programming Language Rust.
Hier, hier, das ist doch schon, das ist doch schon der Thread.
Das habe ich am Mittag gelesen beim Mittagessen.
Und letztendlich, um was es geht, ist eigentlich zweitrangig.
Irgendjemand sagt, er will sein Programm crashen lassen und die einzig verlässliche Variante in Rust,
so wie er sein Programm crashen lassen kann, ist, einen Nullpointer zu dereferenzieren und dann crashts.
Aber was ich viel lustiger finde, sind die Antworten.
Und hier unten drunter gibt es allen Ernstes eine Diskussion.
Diskussion müsst ihr euch haltet euch fest rast leute es gibt allen ernsteste diskussion hier unten drunter
welche methode des crashens
performancetechnisch die beste ist
wer crash schneller
Oder unterhalten sie sich länglich drüber was die beste variante oder die schnellst die
performancemäßig beste variante ist ein programm zu crashen
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, also jetzt
Jetzt drehen sie ab, die Rust, Leute
Jetzt ist es vorbei
Es ist nicht so
Es reicht nicht nur, dass Rust
Placingly fast und written in Rust und alles ist
Nein, Rust muss auch noch am schnellsten
Crashen
Guckt, die unterhalten sich allen Ernstes drüber
Welche Methode des Programm-Crashens
Die beste ist
Da kommt der erste, ne, benutzt Standard-Processor-Board
Da kommt der nächste
Ach ne, ruf das hier auf
Da kommt der nächste, mach Inline-Assembly zum Crashen.
Ich fand das so bescheuert.
Das muss Blazingly Fast crashen, Leute.
Ich hab auch gedacht, jetzt übertreiben sie es aber wirklich.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber echt, Mann.
Es geht aber noch weiter.
Es geht noch weiter.
wird geguckt manche compiler handeln spezielles ding was man angeben kann aber wenn ich jetzt geht gcc verwende
oh man
Ich finde das ist eine vollkommen legitime sache ja wenn ich mein gibt bestimmt schönere variante wenn er einfach crashen will aber er hat
hier sogar geschrieben hat sein hat seinen grund
naja soll er machen
Okay so windows vm
keck windows also wollen wir mal sagt use iso image downloads windows 25 hat zwei englisch
international muss ich sonst irgendwas einstellen naja wir haben erneut secure boot ich glaube das
war's.
Okay, Chat. Wir machen jetzt
das, was ihr gesagt habt. Also,
wenn ich, zumindest manche, ihr habt ja 50
verschiedene Dinger gesagt.
Ähm,
TPM ist, glaube ich, alles schon.
Jaja.
So.
Ihr habt ja mehrere Sachen gesagt. Also, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe,
viele von euch haben gesagt,
einfach starten
mit, ähm, oder was? Moment.
Du brauchst bei Windows
Windows Professional
Moment, hab ich Windows Professional überhaupt runtergeladen, Leute?
Moment, was
hab ich denn runtergeladen überhaupt?
Hab ich?
Ah ne, Moment, das ISO ist
das gleiche, man wählt das ja beim
Installer dann aus, oder?
So war das doch.
Okay.
sagt also was soll ich machen ich soll du sagst einrichten für arbeit
dann andere login methode dann führt okay das machen wir das problem jetzt
aus ob das funktioniert wenn das funktioniert dann frage ich mich warum
die alle so ein riesen aufstand machen
gleich hier heroische background time and currency format da machen wir mal
German. Übrigens, da sieht man
auch mal wieder, wie rotz der
Windows-Installer ist. Man kann hier auswählen
Time and Currency Format Germany, aber wenn
es dann installiert ist, fragt er dich noch mal.
Das ist mir gerade so anstrengend.
Ja, viel, viel
angenehmer.
Warum ist das jetzt aufgeploppt?
ok next german
i agree everything will be deleted yes
gibt kein product key windows 11 professional
die lizenz wird mir man muss er braucht ja gar keine lizenz mehr aus dem habe ich eine lizenz für pro
Dann kommt Windows 12, muss man bei Microsoft anrufen.
searching for disks an allokal space
er hat mich daran als snapshot mache nach der installation bevor dieses ganze zeug
ach so moment muss ich muss ich netzwerk trennen vom reboot oder ist es egal ist egal
okay da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das funktioniert machen wir mal hier
während er installiert da müssen wir nicht zu gucken aber lieber entspannungsprogramm
Exzellent, AskIquarium im Fullscreen.
Leute, wisst ihr, was ein Rohrentlüfter ist?
Ich weiß, randomster Themensprung überhaupt, aber wisst ihr, was ein Rohrentlüfter ist?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich behaupte mal, wahrscheinlich wissen 99% der Weltbevölkerung nicht, was ein Rohrbelüfter ist.
Das ist ein Teil, da steckt man zwischen Wasserhahn und Schlauch, der zum Beispiel zur Waschmaschine geht.
der sorgt unter anderem dafür dass wasser nicht zurück gesaugt werden kann und irgendwie belüftet
die leitung so fragt mich nicht was genau bedeutet zumindest mein rohr belüfter ich
habe das ja letzten auf twitter gepostet weil ich wusste was ist mein rohr belüfter tropft
und da wollte ich mir einfach einen neuen rohr belüfter kaufen und ich dachte mir das ist sie
gehst einfach mal ins baumarkt holst den neuen rohrbelüfter bin ich gestern ins
bauhaus gegangen habe gesagt gucke mal hier so ein ding brauche ich habe gesagt
aha ein rohrbelüfter da und da hängt es es gibt nur eine größe so da okay dann
ist ja kein problem habe ich mir den da gekauft komm heim will ihn dran schrauben
passt nicht gucke ich im internet nach nein es gibt zwei größen es gibt m 28
den M27.
Ich habe einen M27 Wasserhahn und das
war ein M28 Rohrbelüfter.
Aber der Bauhaustyp meinte halt, gibt nur eine
Größe.
Wo wir mal wieder beim Thema sind,
der ganze Einzelhandel, die
Kackspasten, ja, die müssen sich
echt mal nicht beschweren, dass keine
Sau mehr zu ihnen geht.
Kleiner, kleiner Zwischenrage.
Ja, die müssen sich echt nicht
beschweren, dass da keine Sau mehr hingeht und
da irgendwas kauft.
Es ist echt immer die Unfähigkeit in Person
Sei es jetzt Bauhaus, irgendwelche Elektronikläden oder sonst was
Die sind alle immer unfähig
Der unfähigste Laden, wo ich jemals im Leben gewesen bin
Das ist aber schon ganz lange her
War Phobis
Gibt es von euch noch irgendjemand, der Phobis kennt?
Die gibt es nicht mehr, zu Recht
Das war so eine Computerkette
Phobis.
Ja.
Computer, oh, die gibt es immer noch.
Scheiße, das wusste ich gerade.
Dachte, die sind alle pleite.
Hat mich schon gefreut.
Phobis.
Da gab es so alte Dinger.
Da bist du gerne hin.
Ja, ich bin da auch gerne hin, bis zu dieser einen Sache.
Zumindest bei Phobis.
Da war ich noch klein. Ah, es installiert noch.
Da war ich noch klein.
Und da hatte ich einen Drucker.
Das war der Drucker bei meinem allerersten Computer.
Da war ein Lexmark-Drucker da.
Ein Lexmark-Tintenstrahldrucker dabei.
Also das Ding für sich genommen war schon absoluter Schrott.
Warum geht man nicht einfach direkt zu den Fachinstallateuren?
Naja, weil es ein kleines Metallding ist,
was man sogar, wenn man, wenn es nicht so fest drin ist, sogar von Hand rein rausschrauben kann.
Warum soll ich mir da irgendeinen Installationstyp holen, der das macht?
Zumindest war das ein Lexmark-Tintenstrahldrucker und der war für sich genommen schon ganz schöner Schrott.
Und ich wurde jebaited, ich wusste es damals nicht besser, ich wurde jebaited von den Lexmark-Tintendrucker oder Tintentaktik.
Und zwar, dass die Tintenpatronen, die ausgeliefert werden bei Tintenstrahldrucker damals, heute wahrscheinlich immer noch, die sind nicht ganz voll.
Du kannst mit den Patronen, die du mit dem Drucker kaufst, kannst du nur, keine Ahnung, ein Drittel drucken von dem, was du mit einer vollen Patrone drucken kannst.
Und dementsprechend war meine Patrone relativ schnell leer.
Also bin ich damals in den Phobis gegangen und habe mir eine neue Tintendingspatrone gekauft.
beziehungsweise meine Mutter hat es gekauft,
damals war die Männchen, ich war noch klein, ja.
Tintenpatrone für den Drucker.
Da bin ich heimgekommen, hab den Drucker,
hab den Drucker reingemacht,
hab die Tintenpatrone in den Drucker reingemacht
und die hat Schlieren gezogen.
Ich hab
den Druckerkopf gereinigt,
hat immer noch Schlieren gezogen.
Mein Fazit war, die Druckerpatrone
ist kaputt. So.
Da bin ich zum Phobis hingefahren
und hab gesagt, ey,
Die Patrone ist kaputt.
Ich hätte gerne eine neue Patrone, die funktioniert.
Und das Zeug war damals teuer.
Die Patrone hat fast das gleiche gekostet wie der Drucker.
Moment.
So, ähm.
Bin jetzt stehen geblieben.
Genau, die Patrone hat fast das gleiche gekostet wie der Drucker.
Und dann bin ich hingegangen zum Phobis.
Hab gesagt, ich hätte gerne eine neue Patrone.
Die alte ist kaputt.
Haben gesagt, nö, das können sie nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich kann das nachvollziehen, die ist kaputt.
Ja, aber ich hätte die Patrone jetzt ja schon benutzt.
Die können sie nicht zurücknehmen.
Egal, ich will eine neue Patrone haben.
Die ist kaputt, die ihr mir verkauft habt.
Ich war damals, ich war ja damals noch nicht alt.
Ja, ich hab damals übelst schnell geraged, wenn irgendwas war, was nicht nach meiner Vorstellung ging, ja, instant losgeraged und dann meinten sie, ja, aber, nee, genau, dann haben wir gesagt, probiert das doch mal aus, probiert es doch mal aus bei euch, da werdet ihr sehen, die ist kaputt, haben ja keinen Drucker dafür, um das auszuprobieren.
Das Einzige, was wir machen können, und das muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja, was ein dreckiger Kackladen.
Die haben dann zu uns gesagt, das Einzige, was wir machen können, ist, wir sollen heimfahren, meinen Drucker mitbringen und dort vor Ort einen Druck machen, um zu sehen, dass die Patrone nicht geht.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Ich weiß nicht, warum die das gemacht haben, ist klar.
Die haben sich gedacht, das macht keiner.
die leute gehen jetzt heim und halten die klappe aber wir haben das damals
gemacht wir sind mit dem drucker hingefahren und nach langem hin und her
haben wir halt auch eine neue patronen gekriegt aber das hat bestimmt keine
ahnung insgesamt drei stunden oder so gebraucht und seitdem bin ich nie wieder
dahin ich habe jedem abgeraten von den phobias
zu gehen und sobald sich die gelegenheit ergeben hat habe ich vor bis immer
geflamed.
Und damals ging es schon los mit
warum geht dann keiner mehr in den Einzelhandel?
Damals war das mit Internet noch
wirklich so in den Kinderschuhen, ja.
Oder besser gesagt, war vielen einfach noch gar nicht.
Aber ich hab mich damals schon nach der Zeit
gesehnt, wo es ordentliche Online-Versandhandel
gibt.
Ohne es zu wissen, dass ich
nämlich diesen ganzen dreckigen
lokalen Ladenkram
mit den unfähigen Leuten nicht brauch.
So, genug geflamed.
gucken wir mal was die windows installation macht hey wenn das ist fertig wir machen mal
einen snapshot dass wir da wieder zurückkönnen ich jedes mal neu installieren müssen aber da
ich klicke dann zeit mehr wer es mit einem video ja das stimmt das richtig da hast du recht aber
ich habe da irgendwie gerade kein richtigem kopf für wenn ich wenn ich meinen windows
zeug neu installiert habe mit secure boot an und einem aktuellen windows dann
kann ich auch battle für sechs spielen
hat bei dir damals auch ein halbes jahr gedauert da gibt es auch eine story
moment ich klicke jetzt mal windows weiter erzähle ich euch was kleiner max
wollte super nintendo spiele kaufen ist es so weit kann jetzt kommt ja jetzt
Jetzt kommt der Moment der Wahrheit.
Erinnert mich dran.
Weitere Story von
warum lokale Läden kacke sind.
Ist das direkt? Guck mal.
Egal.
Ich beschwere mich nicht.
By the way.
Warum kann ich hier eigentlich nicht G drücken?
Für German. Warum geht das nicht?
Windows? Microsoft?
Wer hat sich gedacht, es ist eine gute Idee,
dass man hier unbedingt durchscrollen muss?
So von Hand.
pc spezialist all dabei den habe ich auch egal dass man das hier so ist
so johann zu er das second keyboard layout es gibt dass du schon mal andere
länder siehst die sich schon an frankfurt auf
Gibt es noch den Geheimtrink mit Land...
International? Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube Candy Crush ist mittlerweile
nicht mehr dabei.
Okay, so.
Jetzt kommt's. Also.
Name your device. Omega Lul.
Next.
Und jetzt?
Hä?
Ah, vielleicht hätte ich jetzt erst einen Snapshot machen sollen.
Händler, damals bei dir ein Schatz Crysis.
Cry ist 3.
Ey, das ist der Wahnsinn, wie unfähig die alle sind, ne?
Wir haben letzte Woche in der Schule alle möglichen Raid-Level aufgehört und mussten Windows...
Okay.
Preisfrage.
Wie viele Platten dürfen bei einem Raid 6 ausfallen?
Wir machen jetzt Übung für die Abschlussprüfung.
Wie viele Platten dürfen bei einem Raid 6 kaputt gehen?
Zwei?
Ist das so?
Ja.
Zwei.
Egal, zwei ist richtig.
Zwei ist richtig.
Und jetzt kommt noch die Bonusfrage.
Chat, ihr habt es bestanden.
High IQ ist wieder confirmed.
Jetzt kommt die Preisfrage.
Wie viele Platten dürfen bei einem Raid...
Wie nennt man das eigentlich richtig?
10 kaputt gehen?
Und wie viele bei einem Raid 0,1?
Raid 0,1 macht man nicht, aber theoretisch ist es möglich.
Wie viele dürfen bei einem Raid 10 kaputt gehen?
Und wie viele bei einem Raid 0,1?
So.
Nachdem wir das haben, dann machen wir die Windows-Installation.
Du hast nicht, also
Raid-Level habe ich zum größten Teil
im Kopf, obwohl ich das eigentlich gar nicht brauche.
Na, wisst ihr es?
Wie viel dürfen meine Raid 10 ausfallen?
Abschlussprüfung erst in einem Jahr.
Jetzt snapshotten, du hast recht.
Du hast recht.
Jetzt snapshotten.
Okay, Chat,
Also jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht.
Wir haben so viele Fisis hier, hätte ich gedacht, das wisst ihr.
Jetzt muss ich mich nämlich outen, dass ich mir selbst nicht hundertprozentig sicher bin.
Ich glaube, bei einem RAID 10 darf eine ausfallen, auf jeden Fall maximal zwei.
Ich glaube, es hängt bei der zweiten Platte, bei einem RAID 10, davon ab, wo die zweite ausfällt.
Wenn die quasi
Auf der gleichen Seite ausfällt
Wie
Die erste ist kaputt
Wenn die auf der anderen Seite ausfällt ist okay
Genau
Eine auf jeden Fall
Und zwei wenn du Glück hast
Warum 1 0
der Unterschied, also Raid 10, das eine ist
du hast zwei Platten, jeweils
zweimal zwei Platten mit Raid 0,
darüber einen Raid 1 oder
zweimal zwei Platten mit einem Raid 1
und darüber einen Raid 0.
Das ist theoretisch, aber 0,1 macht
eigentlich keiner.
Du hast oben schon geschrieben.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Excellent.
Okay, gerade nochmal gerettet hast du den Chat.
so also jetzt war jetzt kommt was wir machen wir müssen sagen für für work
setup wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe und jetzt sein in options domain
Join instead.
Und jetzt gebe ich
Enter your name, Max.
Next.
Enter Passwort.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Boah, Alter.
Oh, überspringen.
Hätte ich das überspringen können? Jetzt zu spät. Moment, Snapshot Restore.
Ach so, ja egal, egal, egal. Ich mach das jetzt hier.
So, Fragen beantwortet.
Wie, das war's jetzt? Aber ich hab doch noch nicht mal eine Domain angegeben,
auf die ich joinen will.
Jetzt glaube ich noch nicht,
dass es das jetzt war.
Das war's?
Ja, sind die alle geistig irgendwie
nicht mehr auf der Höhe auf Reddit oder was?
Dass die sich darüber aufregen.
Wo ist das Problem? Das ist ja noch einfacher als vorher jetzt.
Das ist doch easy as fuck.
Was ist denn die ganze Aufregung?
Ich habe immer OOB-Experience
und so gemacht.
Das ist doch easy as fuck.
Geht das auch mit der Non-Pro?
Ne, ich glaube nicht.
Aber scheiß drauf.
doch egal ob das pro oder home ist wo es geht ich habe schon immer pro installiert
die lizenzkosten du musst es noch nicht mal aktivieren
und kannst du ein mann kann doch windows 11 immer noch mit alten windows 7 keys aktivieren
oder?
Sollte gehen.
Ja, siehste?
Also keine Ahnung, wo da jetzt
das Problem ist.
Was macht
der eigentlich gerade?
was passiert hier gerade?
Ah, almost there.
Ach, ich vergesse immer, wie hässlich Windows 11 ist,
wenn es standardmäßig da am Start ist.
So, jetzt müssen wir das ganze Ding ja noch verschlüsseln
und gucken, ob das alles funktioniert.
Weil ich muss das ausprobieren, bevor ich meinen Rechner hier umstelle.
Ich habe mir ja bei Amazon eine SSD gekauft,
eine zweite. Ach guck mal, heute habe ich wieder eine andere Postleitzahl. KQ9999 Pro habe ich mir bestellt mit 4 Terabyte.
Ich habe jetzt aktuell die mit 2 Terabyte, jetzt habe ich mir die mit 4 Terabyte bestellt und die werde ich einfach
parallel zu meiner jetzt schon bestehenden
Windows, also SSD reinhauen
und dann drauf installieren
und sobald alles geht, halt nur noch die benutzen.
Hast du das
mit der Verschlüsselung schon probiert? Doch!
Aber angeblich gibt es mit Veracrypt
ab Windows 24
H2, glaube ich,
Probleme.
Deswegen
probiere ich das jetzt nochmal aus.
Jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal Forever Tools
installieren damit wir das zeug überhaupt schreibt benutzen können install firma tools
und jetzt bei tools run yes
der ort sieht nice aus der beste ort windows hintergrund ist immer noch windows xp background
ich muss sagen aus meiner sicht ist windows xp sp2 oder sp3 mir eigentlich egal was beste windows
was bisher gegeben hat wenn das xp war das letzte windows wo man das gefühl hat das war irgendwie
so aus einem guss zumindest so zu 95 prozent was meinst du mit verschlüsseln die festplatte
verschlüsseln du musst dann quasi beim beim booten ein passwort eingeben wenn das nicht
machst der computer nicht benutzbar wenn aus ihm war aber schon ein bisschen mehr zerstückelt
aber wenn noch sieben ging auch noch klar mit locker nebel locker kommt mir nicht ins haus
so ristat komme hier die cd disconnecten er war ein priester hatte der dann jetzt
ich bin immer wieder begeistert wie laggy teilweise windows 11 ist ich habe vor wir
hatten wir hatten ja mal vor zwei drei jahren oder so haben wir noch 98 installiert bei mir
noch 98 war das echt so du hast was geklickt es ist instant was passiert wirklich instant also
hast noch nicht mal die maus richtig oben gehabt den button oder oder runter ich weiß gar nicht
ob es auf maus dauern oder ab reagiert und es war instant da ja gut wisst aber schrott wobei vieles
was in vista eingeführt wurde ist halt auch vom unterbau her heute noch am start ja auch
diese dynamik dynamische window manager dass die transparenz haben kannst und so was das ist
alles windows vista kommen so dass immer dann als erstes was ist ja eigentlich für ein ganzer
Shit schon wieder dabei. Was ist das?
Windows Store. Okay. Windows Store wird schon mal
unpinnt. Neues Outlook braucht
auch kein Mensch. Weg.
Edge brauche ich jetzt auch nur.
Moment. Moment, Leute. Ha!
Pass mal auf.
Man kann das nicht...
Ernsthaft, man kann das nicht beenden.
Reboot!
genau wenn die task manager auch funktioniert habe ich habe mir gedacht
genau ich will wenn gett wenn gett firefox will ich machen okay dieses
hässliche Widget-Ding da unten.
Geh mal weg.
Geh weg!
Widget.
Piss dich, Aldo!
Und wie ging das nochmal? Widget-Taskbar-Settings.
Widgets. Bam.
Bam.
Search. Hide.
Äh.
Wo stelle ich das nochmal auf?
auf taskbar Behaviors.
Left.
Ha, jetzt sieht das wieder halbwegs normal aus.
Share any window from...
Was bedeutet das überhaupt?
Share any window from my taskbar.
Was bedeutet das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was dieses Setting überhaupt bedeuten soll.
Wollen wir nicht?
Ach, für Teams.
Combine, never.
Gut, jetzt kann man das wenigstens wieder bedienen.
Okay, Icos hat eine Theorie.
Und zwar schreibt, ich habe eine Theorie, weshalb Microsoft nicht plötzlich alle Wege stoppt.
Wenn man seiner Kundschaft zu viel auf einmal wegnimmt, dann werden sie wütend.
Deswegen wäre es taktisch schlau, es nur nach und nach komplizierter zu machen.
Dann sind nicht alle Kunden auf einmal wütend.
So ähnliches Gefühl habe ich.
Das ist auch so.
Gebe ich dir vollkommen recht.
Das ist so ein bisschen Salami-Taktik
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass genau das der Grund ist
Heute gibt es kein Battlefield-Stream
Das ist ja nur in der VM
Start in der Mitte mag ich nicht
Weil da muss man zielen
Und hier kann man einfach in die linke untere Ecke
Du musst ja hier unten gar nicht richtig draufklicken
Du kannst den Mauszeiger einfach
In die linke untere Ecke schmeißen und klicken
Und das geht
Du kannst mit Windows-Taste drücken
funktioniert bypass ob noch nicht braucht man nicht man geht einfach auf in domäne
aufnehmen und dann kann man lokalen account anlegen easy ok jetzt schau mal firefox wir
installieren das war firefox über wind get wind wind geht so bei dem warum gibt es hier keine
tab completion der completion ist outdated overrated gebetet search firefox
ja wie er natürlich
mozilla firefox alter wie viel zum
allein schon dass da jedes einzelne dinge angezeigt wird ist schon wieder absolut
omega 0 die anderen ms store hier mozilla firefox firefox will ich wahrscheinlich
installieren wenn get install in powershell gibt es ein tab ok
massive ach jetzt dann einfach nur gebraucht der musste quasi irgend einen
command index oder so erstellt ok install firefox
in react sagt es mal nicht so laut microsoft scheint ja react fan zu sein
das office ist auch also office im browser ist auch eine react anwendung zum größten teil
office 365 das startmenü ist auch react wirklich ernsthaft ich meine nicht dass ich es nicht für
möglich halten würde ich habe gedacht das startmenü ist wenigstens wenn ui
sag mal benutzt microsoft eigentlich selber wenn ui oder haben wir auch
festgestellt dass das abgrundtiefer schrott ist und das gibt es nur noch auf
dem papier und sie haben keine entwicklerressourcen für video und
benutzen wir selber nicht also wenn ui ist das aktuelle in anführungszeichen ui
framework für windows was aber niemand benutzt was auch ziemlich erschrocken ist
vom ansatz her gar nicht so übel
maui oder der unter windows benutzt maui wahrscheinlich video denke ich mal
ist ja auch so zum rollkrepierer also das einzig sinnvolle cross platform was
ich für dort nette ausprobiert habe ist avalon ja wobei ich letztens auf red gelesen habe dass
uno auch nicht schlecht sein soll kannst du ein bitte forser runterladen wieso das dass wir dieses
mien hier nach stellen können so bei ist ja super interessant so leute forser als runtergeladen
Avalonia machte einen ganz guten Eindruck.
Aber was mich bei diesem ganzen, was ich bei WPF und bei Avalonia und bei Uno,
würde es mich wahrscheinlich auch nerven.
Ich bin überhaupt kein Fan von diesem XML-GUI-Gedöns.
So, aber jetzt haben wir Firefox.
Zack, close, bam, Firefox am Start.
Continue.
So jetzt erstmal das wichtigste in firefrog origin installieren
except
You blog origin
Vom ray raymond hill ist der richtige
Private windows
Mit extension so jetzt haben wir block jetzt alles gut
Moment, nur dass ich das jetzt richtig verstehe.
Das heißt, du machst ein Webview
und darin dann mit Blazer das Frontend, oder wie?
Boah, das ist aber echt schon auch ganz schön durch die Brust ins Auge, oder?
aber im prinzip würde ich wahrscheinlich ehrlich machen also ich würde dann auch für keine
anwendung mehr aus als es nicht wirklich was was native integriert sein muss wie hier zum beispiel
dieses ding was die images mal hier diese aufwahl ist das teil was die overlays malt das muss eine
native anwendung sein weil es muss ja in windows denken den kram anzeigen können aber wenn ich
einfach nur konfigurations-ui machen wollen würde dann würde ich das auch mit einer webseite machen
einfach eine webseite die irgendwie auf localhost 5100 5 keine ahnung lauscht und es ein knopfhahn
gibt so startet halt webseiten browser mit mit der website zu konfigurieren brauchst kein native
weil native ui in der regel abfuck ist leider es ist unter linux abfuck es ist
unter windows abfuck und unter mobile weiß ich nicht genau weil ich noch nicht
gemacht habe
so das immer am stimmte erfolgs hat er jetzt werbung des miss
Ist Miss.
Ist Miss hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Ist Miss. Otto.
Deutscher Otto Lahn.
So. Gut.
Firefox Vera Crypt downloaden.
Mal schauen ob das funzt.
Ich mache noch einmal
einen Snapshot.
Danach müssen wir unbedingt alle Snapshots weghauen.
Falls wir die Windows Kiste behalten.
Das wird ja mit der Zeit viel zu groß.
Ja gut, du kannst es ja mit Web machen.
Also so wie ich meine ist, wenn du eine Anwendung bastelst, die eine Konfigurationsinterface haben soll,
da kannst du ja auch die Anwendung starten, lokal einen Web-Server aufmachen und einen Browser öffnen, der da drauf geht.
Dann hast du ja auch quasi eine Konfigurations-UI, nur dass es halt eine Web-Anwendung ist.
ich gebe dir recht schöner ist es wenn man taskbar integration hat und dann auch mal anklicken kann
und so aber nachdem ich war microsoft hat ja gar nichts aktuell für für native ui auf ihrer eigenen
plattform elektron ist dann das nächste wenn du wirklich native integration in irgendeiner art und
weise brauchst dann greifen hat viele zu elektron als einigen den aufwand reduziert um verschiedene
anwendungen zu bauen also es ist halt schon ein witz dass microsoft seit
an und seit windows 7 oder so selbst da schon nett eigentlich eigentlich hat
microsoft kein gescheites desktop framework seit wpf unter windows xp
damals rausgekommen ist und wpf ist halt auch nicht schön meiner meinung nach
also ist alles schrott also native native ui auf desktop ist irgendwie alles
paint champ das beste finde ich ist immer noch cute also qt aber qt ist halt
c++ zum größten teil spätestens mal ein paar custom sachen machen will kommst du
am c++ nicht vorbei und das ist halt das ist halt auch schon für sich genommen
wieder eklig
so
wenn ich wenn ich den windows native anwendung machen würde ohne mist wahrscheinlich wenn es
irgendwas funktionales sein soll was durchaus hässlich sein darf wenn ui nicht wenn ui windows
forms ohne mist also das overlay hier das was diese bilder hier mal zum beispiel das ist wpf
das ist wpf wegen der transparenz weil das mal das fenster guck das fenster ist ja so eigentlich
und die transparenz gegen halt bei wpf ganz gut
man kriegt das übrigens auch mit windows forms hin dass das vor das fonds auch da muss man sich
aber selbst darum kümmern wie man die wie man gifs und sowas rendert kann man dann ffm pack
oder sowas für benutzen.
Da steige ich auch nicht durch.
Die haben sich da selbst
auch ein bisschen ins Knie geschossen, dass das seit
Jahrzehnten so kompliziert ist.
Ja, das Linux...
Immer das darauf folgende Ja ist das Ja
des Linux-Systems.
Ich habe schon Anwendungen gesehen,
die benutzen eine Game Engine für
Cross-Plattform-UI. Das finde ich
auch gar nicht so abwegig, ehrlich gesagt.
Das läuft halt einfach auch auf allen Plattformen.
Also ich habe einen...
Ich benutze für...
Wenn ich Dark Age of Camelot spiele, das ist so ein uraltes MMO.
Warum ist denn meine Musik, by the way?
Ah, YouTuber wieder gecrashed.
Benutze ich ein Programm, um Ausrüstung zu planen für das Game.
Und das ist, glaube ich, in Unity programmiert.
und läuft dementsprechend
auf allen Plattformen,
theoretisch, wo Unity läuft.
Das ist ein GUI-Programm, was
in Unity programmiert ist.
Rust ist immer ein bisschen
Pain.
Also, meine
These ist ja, was Sachen wie Rust
angeht, das hat auf jeden Fall
seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Also nicht, dass jetzt die Krustentiere sich
irgendwie hier gleich wieder im Chat aufregen
müssen. Rust hat auf jeden Fall seine
Daseinsberechtigung, hauptsächlich
dort, wo es wichtig ist,
so hohe Performance
wie möglich zu haben und
so memory safe wie
möglich zu sein. Das sind Kombinationen.
Möglichst
wenig Runtime-Checks,
dass du nicht irgendwie aus dem Array
raus wobei das was auch zur runtime checken muss ja oder das in den thread
aus dem scope gegangen ist und jetzt oder irgendwelche pointer die nicht mehr
gültig sind und gefried wurden so das kannst du bei rust alles zur
compile zeit quasi ausschließen und hast dann raw performance und so memory safe
wie möglich wenn dieser kombination beispiel zum beispiel so was wie einen
webbrowser wäre wenn man heute damit halt neu anfängt wahrscheinlich ein gutes
ding für rust weil es muss sicher sein das ist eines der wenigen anwendungen wo
als da noch wirklich auch darauf ankommt dass da nichts drin ist weil bei einem
spiel was passiert bei einem spiel wenn es da irgendwie irgendwelche point das
nicht richtig der crash das game und war es auch ja gerade bei single player
spiel eigentlich ziemlich egal aber eine browser sieht es anders aus browser
führt ja quasi ganzen tag nur fremde sachen aus fremden javascript fremdes
html css zeug wenn es da irgendwelche bugs im parser gibt wurde ausbrechen
kannst aus der sandbox der ganze rechner klein am arsch und gerade so was wie ein
browser könnte ich mir vorstellen heutzutage wäre rast wahrscheinlich echt
eine gute basis gut niemand der noch halbwegs bei sinnes fängt eine neue
browser engine oder neue browser an aber wenn man heute quasi neue browser
anfangen würde dafür finde ich rast gar nicht schlecht
sind schnell und das ist doch firefox in firefox laufen sogar soweit ich weiß
einige teile schon im wir sind schon den rast implementiert aber ein browser muss
schnell sein und er muss memory so memory safe wie möglich sein dafür ist
was super für alles andere finde ich was schlechter als sagen wir mal go oder
dort net oder sonst was der entwicklung speed in rust ist einfach langsamer als
in anderen sprachen
Wenn man Leute vergleicht, die das gleiche Know-How haben, wenn du jetzt den ultra krassen Rust-Pro nimmst, der seine Lead-Code-Aufgaben nur in Rust macht und im Schlaf den Binary-Tree invertet in Rust, versus jemand, der frisch mit Go angefangen hat, natürlich kriegt er da Sachen besser und schneller hin.
Aber ich, eine Sache, du wirst schneller einen halbwegs brauchbaren Stand haben in Go, vom Können her, von Skills her, um darin was zu erstellen, als in Rust.
Und wenn du einen hast, der ganz brauchbar Rust kann, einen, der ganz brauchbar Go kann, .NET, Java, was auch immer, der wird die Anwendung einfach schneller fertiggestellt haben, als in Rust.
oder sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt schneller,
aber wenn man
schneller fertigstellt, der wird halt
schneller sein. Das heißt, die Anwendung kann dann am
Ende mehr oder ist schneller, neue Features
einzubauen und sonst was.
Deswegen finde ich, Rust hat seine Daseinsberechtigung,
aber an Stellen,
wo die Vorteile von Rust
da nicht notwendig sind,
finde ich, macht Rust auch keinen Sinn.
Das hat es dir angetan, ne?
Übrigens, jetzt hier, weil jemand schreibt, Gage, ich habe letztens eine Anzeige bekommen auf Reddit.
Ganz weirde Anzeige, wo ich auch gedacht habe, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Da stand irgendwie, für dich gehören jetzt...
ich vergesse bestimmt irgendwas weil ich mittlerweile das gar nicht mal alles
merken kann das war eine anzeige gehören für dich lgbtq aijy was auch immer das
geht ja mittlerweile ist das geht es ja über die halbe seite bis zu einer
abkürzung drin hast plus und c++ zusammen fragezeichen habe ich mir
gelesen also
Ist das wirklich eine gute Idee, dass irgendwas, egal was es ist, mit C++ zusammengehört?
Also alles, was mit C++ zusammengehört, hat doch eigentlich schon die Arschkarte, oder?
Niemand will mit C++ freiwillig was zu tun haben.
Also, die Anzeige habe ich nicht so ganz gecheckt.
Hätten sie da meinetwegen
Go oder .NET oder so reingeschrieben?
Ja, okay, aber C++?
Ich verstehe C++-Enthusiasten nicht.
Ich meine, ihr wisst,
C++ ist in meinen Top 5 Programmiersprachen drin.
Aber nicht, weil C++ so toll ist.
sondern wie habe ich das letztens genannt? Wisst ihr, manchmal gibt es auch eklige Sachen,
die Spaß machen können und C++ ist sowas. C++ ist eklig, aber das was man mit C++ machen kann,
das gebasteln macht halt Spaß. Zum Beispiel Microcontroller programmieren und C++ ist
halt so abartig und wirr, dass es teilweise schon lustig ist und deswegen Spaß macht.
also meine top 5 programmier sprachen hatten wir schon öfters auf den ersten beiden plätzen
ist ruby und sie schafft sich hat benutze ich bei weitem mehr als ruby ruby hat sich
die letzten jahre über auf dem absteigenden ast befunden und deswegen macht mache ich
eigentlich so gut wie nix mehr in Ruby, aber Ruby ist
eine super Programmiersprache.
Ruby ist, finde ich, fast die schönste
Programmiersprache, die es gibt.
Leider ist Ruby on Rails auf dem Absteigen
und Ruby selbst, es gibt kaum noch neue
Ruby-Sachen.
Der einzige
gefühlt, der noch Ruby-Projekte
manchmal macht, ist
DHH, der Typ mit
Ruby on Rails und, wie hieß das
Linux nochmal, ich hab's schon wieder vertragen,
Omachi, genau.
Der macht manchmal noch Ruby-Sachen auf GitHub.
Aber ansonsten, es gibt sehr wenig Ruby-Sachen.
Aber Ruby ist eine super Programmiersprache.
Das hört man oft.
Du meinst, du meinst Ruby?
Dass Ruby eine schöne Programmiersprache ist?
Ja.
Java ist nicht auf meiner Top-5-Liste.
Ist der?
Woher soll ich das... Hä? Keine Ahnung.
Das ist aber auch nichts, was ich hier diskutieren will,
was da irgendwelche Leute auf GitHub machen.
So, also C Sharp, Ruby.
Das nächste ist tatsächlich, man kann es kaum glauben, JavaScript.
JavaScript ist eine richtig gute Programmiersprache mittlerweile.
JavaScript wird immer geflamed.
Und wir haben uns ja letztens ein Video angeguckt,
verschiedene Date Formats in JavaScript.
und 0 ist 2001 der 12.1. oder irgendwie so komische Dinger.
Also JavaScript hat ganz viele super weird champige Sachen.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen, wenn man das nicht absichtlich die verrückten Sachen benutzt,
ist JavaScript eine echt nice Sprache.
TypeScript ist nicht in meinen Top 5 dabei.
javascript ist da ist also hätten wir dort netz sie als sie schab ruby javascript als nächstes
muss ich tatsächlich sagen ist es go ich fliege ganz gut auch ich fliege ganz gerne auch mal
hauptsächlich weil es aus mir nicht erkundlichen gründen in der standard
library teilweise sehr minimalistisch ist und auf der anderen seite wieder
nicht aber go ist so eine sprache die finde ich jetzt nicht super schön oder
so aber ich glaube ich habe mehr sachen in go jemals fertig bekommen als in
jeder anderen programmiersprache also wenn es irgendwas ist was ich just for fun mache und
ich gern viel basteln und ausprobieren und was besonders schön machen will oder sonst was da
mache ich das sind sie schab wenn ich irgendwas will was einfach fertig wird und in einem single
binary am ende auch easy läuft ist es einfach das beste vercontainerisieren lässt sich auch
super. Nimmst du Distroless
Image, schiebst dein
Go-Binary rein, es geht und am Ende
hast du ein 8-11 MB großes
Container-Image mit deinem Binary
drin, was alles macht, was du haben willst. Also ich
habe in Go schon mehr Sachen fertig bekommen
als in jeder anderen Programmiersprache.
Deswegen Go funzt
einfach. Ja, Go ist einfach so
ein Ding, das kann man
immer nehmen, wenn
irgendwas schnell bei rauskommen soll.
So.
Und die fünfte
Programmiersprache in meinen Top 5 ist
tatsächlich C++. Nicht, weil
ich C++ sonderlich mag,
sondern
ich mag die Sachen, die man mit C++
macht, nämlich zum Beispiel Microcontroller
programmieren. Und ich muss sagen,
C++
hat gute Sachen
oder sagen wir mal so, hat schlechte Sachen
oder wie sage ich das am besten?
Hat einige schlechte Sachen,
die trotzdem Spaß machen können.
so kann man es am besten ausdrücken
zum Beispiel Templates
ist so übelst abartiger
Kram, wirklich
das Schlimmste was es gibt, aber du kannst
da drin schon ganz nice Sachen machen
zum Beispiel
ich kenne keine andere Sprache
wo man
zur Compile Zeit
checken kann
ob
also wenn man ein Array hat
sagen wir mal man hat ein Array mit 15
mit 15 Plätzen
da kann man in C++ zur Compile-Zeit
checken
ob man quasi was
größeres als 15 Stellen
da reinschreibt so
also das
und eine Custom-Compiler-Warnung ausgeben
also das hat schon
ein paar ganz coole Sachen
An sich ist C++ halt abartig as fuck, inkonsistent as fuck und ich frage mich, was das C++ Gremium eigentlich treibt.
Aber nachdem ich gerne Microcontroller bastle, ist C++ immer noch beste dafür.
So, dann haben wir mal den Top 5 Programmiersprachen.
Also C Sharp, Ruby, JavaScript, Go und C++.
und ich muss sagen weil irgendjemand geschrieben hat wo ich ja war übrigens bin ich wahrscheinlich
einer wenigen wo preislichen top 5 ist die peitsche ist ja mit neben javascript somit
die beliebteste programmiersprache ist aktuell gibt für mich ist peitschen immer ein bisschen
paint champ zu programmieren vielleicht weil ich noch nicht so richtig größere sachen oder viel
damit gemacht habe aber immer wenn ich damit was machen will finde ich eklig ist nicht mein fall
peinchen ist ein bash aber du verwendest auch nur sachen aus der standard library
oder weil dependency management und anwendung verteilen in peinchen ist hardcore paint champ
Typescript, Typescript ist bei mir nicht in den Top 5.
Und Java, weil irgendjemand hat Java geschrieben.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das war.
Ach genau, was ist mit Java und Rust?
Java ist bei mir echt, seitdem ich das letzte Mal mir angeguckt habe,
mit Spring Boot zusammen, muss ich sagen,
das ist echt gar nicht so schlecht.
Ich würde es nicht sagen, ich bin besonders scharf drauf,
was in Java zu machen, aber das,
was wir hier im Stream gemacht haben,
wir haben ja irgendwie vier, fünf Streams
Spring Boot gelernt, das war
wirklich okay. Also ich hätte
keine Schmerzen, mal irgendwas in Java
machen zu müssen.
Das geht, klar.
Habe ich, ob ich mittlerweile mein Java
Praktikum gemacht habe? Ne, habe ich noch nicht
gemacht.
wozu jetzt java anfangen wenn man sich ab hat er zum beispiel weil man das java ökosystem benutzen
möchte oder zum beispiel weil man android anwender machen will oder uns mal ganz einfach zu sagen im
business enterprise kontext wo halt java als default stack gesetzt ist zu php kann ich
nix sagen. PHP
ewig nicht gemacht. Ich glaube, wir haben
haben wir nicht in einem
Stream von einem Jahr oder so mal PHP
gemacht?
Wait a minute. Chat?
Warum Snapshot?
Warum Snapshot hat der immer noch?
Der Snapshot ist seit drei Jahren
schon.
Oder hört
er etwa?
Ist meine Festplatte jetzt? Hat er meine Festplatte voll geschrieben mit dem Snapshot?
Naja, fast.
The fuck?
Ich hatte vorher noch 150 MB frei.
Keck Windows, Alter!
Okay, nochmal gucken, ob das jetzt startet.
Ja.
Aber Java geht echt klar
Ich freu mich auch schon drauf, ein bisschen Java
Mal im Business Enterprise Umfeld
Zu programmieren
Mal gucken, ob was sie mich überhaupt machen lassen
Als Java Noob
Ja
Ich kann ganz brauchbar programmieren
Aber Java hab ich kein Plan
Außer hier ein bisschen Spring Boot
Also das
Ich kann, Java konnte ich
Seit Jahren schon ordentlich lesen
Und hätte auch ein bisschen schreiben können
Also wirklich großartig was gemacht
habe ich damit nie.
Und
das Einzige, was ich jetzt in letzter Zeit gemacht habe,
ist halt diese Springboot-Anwendung im Stream.
Und das ging echt klar. Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt,
was die mich machen lassen.
Rust!
Ehrlich gesagt
hält sich Rust für mich in Grenzen.
Ich habe mich ja gerade vorhin schon über Rust
ausgelassen und es hat auf jeden Fall seine Daseinsweise.
berechtigung habe ich jetzt ja schon länger ausgeführt von der viertelstunde
aber ich finde was ist einfach keine gute sprache wo du sagst das ist ja zu
meinen default choice für was ein satz das ist jetzt mein default choice ja
also das wäre jetzt also für so die standardauswahl so für
programmier sprachen finde ich ist einfach nicht das richtige
Wenn ich jetzt sage, ey, ich will mal was ausprobieren
Mit was mache ich es? Mit Rust
Ich finde dafür ist Rust nicht das richtige
Rust ist gut dafür, wo es halt seine Vorteile hat
Möglichst schnell zu sein, möglichst memory safe zu sein
Wenn ich jetzt einfach mal was ausprobieren will, würde ich das nicht in Rust machen
Trotzdem ist Rust nice
Aber nicht in meinen Top 5
Also wenn ich den Top 10 machen müsste
Wenn ich den Top 10 machen würde
Da würde ich wahrscheinlich Java und Rust reinpacken.
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ja, das ist ja auch eines der Vorteile davon.
das soll sau schnell was an start kriegst das ist übrigens das ist genau das soll ich sagen
so dass das das umgedrehte beispiel zu rast was du was du jetzt hast das ist eigentlich für ein
neues goldenes pixel her das genau umgedreht baras habe ich auch gesagt also ich finde rast
ist halt langsamer als andere programm also also die durchschnittsprogrammier sprache also ich
Ich meine, nicht im Ausführen, sondern in der Entwicklungsgeschwindigkeit.
Und Python ist quasi das Gegenteil.
Da würde ich sogar sagen, da hast du schneller was am Start zusammengewurschtelt,
als in den Durchschnitts anderen Programmiersprachen.
Finde ich.
So.
Zu PHP kann ich nichts sagen
Achso, ja, weil ich gucken wollte
Wann wir zuletzt mal PHP gemacht haben
PHP
Ich use PHP, by the way
Vor zwei Jahren haben wir PHP-Stells gemacht
Laravel, oder? Ist das
Das war abartig
Das war richtig eklig, man
Kann ich mich noch dran erinnern
Es war so eklig, dass ich das niemals wieder danach benutzen wollte
Also, Laravel ist
Im Vergleich zu PHP ist es so
Raw Oldschool PHP immer noch
um Längen angenehmer, aber
Laravel hat
mich ein bisschen dran erinnert, als hat sich einer
Sachen von Ruby on Rails abgeguckt
und das in PHP gegossen.
Nur halt
in eklig.
Ja, Laravel ist
nice. Das ist okay, aber trotzdem ist es abartig.
Aber C Sharp kannst du nur mit
Maui machen auf Android und Maui ist halt
auch Pain.
Also wisst ihr, wenn ich eine Mobile-Anwendung bauen würde, ich hab davon, by the way, das ist nicht auf irgendwie praktische Erfahrung begründet, was ich jetzt sag, ne?
Aber so wie es in meinem Kopf ist, wenn ich eine Mobile-Anwendung machen müsste, dann würde ich zwei Sachen mir angucken.
Ähm
Ich hab, wie heißt das?
Äh
Ionic
Und Flutter
Das wären wahrscheinlich die zwei Sachen, die ich mir angucken würde
Ich hab aber keine Ahnung, ob das noch aktuell ist
Oder das wirklich eine gute Idee ist
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
nicht das einzige was dort kommt gekauft hat wir haben ein paar produkte jetzt
kommt hat mir letztens meine abteilungs alle hand und hat uns unser
abteilungsleiter erzählt wir haben wir haben ein produkt von
broadcom im einsatz sagen das kostet jetzt ich sag jetzt irgendwas das hat
nichts mit der realität zu tun ja ich sag jetzt einfach was das kostet 10.000
euro lizenzgebühren im jahr und platt kommt hat gesagt die lizenzgebühren
werden jetzt um das 16-fache erhöht
daraufhin hat sich unsere war mir nicht was das ist die leute die sich um
software lizenzierung und sowas kümmern hat sich mit broadcom mit broadcom in
verbindung gesetzt hat gesagt kommt wenn ihr 16-fache lizenzgebühren dafür wollt
dann werden wir das ablösen durch irgendeine andere software und dann hat
Prodcom gesagt, ach so, okay.
Ja, okay, dann müsst ihr nur zweimal so viel zahlen.
Also dann müsst ihr nur das Doppelte zahlen.
Und dann haben die gesagt,
jawohl, machen wir.
Und das heißt,
wir freuen uns jetzt, dass wir nur das
Doppelte wie vorher bezahlen müssen.
Das musst du auch erst mal schaffen, oder?
Dass du happy bist,
dass du nur noch das Doppelte bezahlen musst.
Das ist richtig, richtig
stonks, Alter.
da ist die kiste aber warum ist ja war ein böses enterprise überhaupt so beliebt ich
glaube das liegt daran weil es schon richtig lange gibt und das war früher sein und jetzt
oracle die haben halt in der tür was enterprise sachen angeht ich glaube ja
war einfach zur richtigen zeit am richtigen ort als viele anwendungen
gestartet wurden business enterprise umfeld aber ja war gerade der neueste
schritt und das hat sich so durchgesetzt
also die letzten zwei arbeitgeber wo ich war wobei ich nicht stimmt nicht die
letzten drei die haben ihre anwendung zum größten teil in java entwickelt
ich glaube das ist einfach eine kombination aus es ist verbreitet
dementsprechend findest du gute jobs dementsprechend finden die leute
Angestellte.
Das Ökosystem ist relativ
umfangreich und groß und erprobt.
Die Unternehmen haben
Erfahrung mit Java.
Die wissen auch, was sie sich da einlassen.
Im Zweifelsfall kannst du dir irgendwelche Enterprise
Support-Gedöns von Oracle kaufen, wenn du das
unbedingt haben willst. Es gibt
zig
Production-Ready, was auch immer das heißen mag,
Enterprise-Crate
Libraries und
Application-Server und alles mögliche.
Es gibt viele Unternehmen, die benutzen es erfolgreich.
Und das ist, glaube ich, einfach so die Kombination aus allem, weshalb Java so beliebt ist.
Durchgesetzt hat sich Java auch schon lange, bevor es Container gab.
Java ist ja irgendwie von 2000 oder so.
Oder 99 oder irgendwas.
Java.
Oh, kramping.
1991 und 95 1995 ja
ok eins kann ich dir dazu sagen also du sagst ja hier zurzeit bist du eher go type script
rast c go für bestes die speed performance was also dacke rust wird im enterprise business
umfeld nicht benutzt das liegt aber zum größten teil an es gibt kaum was jobs
und es gibt kaum leute die mir fast auskennen das gleiche typescript für
frontend sachen ja recht beliebt im business enterprise umfeld würde ich
würde ich mal sagen vielleicht sogar beliebter wie wie markisches javascript
selbst und bei go ist es halt auch so ein ding ich würde mal sagen es gibt
gibt durchaus Go-Jobs,
aber immer noch weniger als
Java-Jobs.
Rate ich jetzt,
dass das so ist.
Bin mir aber relativ sicher.
Ja, aber das ist Rust-Sick,
das ist eindeutig, da ist die Verbreitung
nicht hoch genug und dementsprechend macht keiner
darin Projekte und es gibt keine Jobs und deswegen
findest du auch keine Leute. Das ist so ein
Ding, was sich selbst irgendwie so
in den Schwanz beißt.
Such mal jemanden, der sich
überleg dir mal du bist ein business enterprise laden der eine software entwickelt die für die
verkaufen will und sich denkt das ist ja zu unserer unsere unser flaggschiff für die nächsten
15 jahre würdest du das heute wirklich in rust anfangen weil du musst ja schon angst haben wenn
die deine jetzigen rast entwickler mit denen oder starten willst abspringen findest du keine neue
mehr
also das würde ich nicht machen und und generell sind sind die da sehr risikoscheu
was so neue sachen angeht also da wird nicht einfach das neueste benutzt nur
weil es vielleicht ein bisschen schneller ein bisschen gehypt da ist
sondern wenn ihr die auswahl haben zwischen rast oder java wird im business
enterprise umfeld das zu neun prozent auf java fallen was aber auch nicht
falsch ist muss man ja mal dazu sagen ja also neben dem was ich alles
schon gesagt habe kommt ja auch noch dazu dass der entwicklung speed aus meiner sicht in java
schneller ist als in rust gar nicht verkehrt man kann dort net auch roh auf android machen
Echt, wirklich? Geht das?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es...
Okay.
Aber das ist bestimmt eklig,
wenn ich Raw-Java-Bindings
aufrufe, oder?
Das wird es bei uns nicht geben.
Ja, PWA ist halt eklig unter iOS.
Ja, das stimmt.
Wir müssen übrigens demnächst auch ein bisschen Go basteln.
Ich wollte mal SQLite in Go
mir mal angucken, so wie es da aussieht
mit ORM-Geschichten und so.
Nie gemacht in Go.
Gibt es eine geile Alternative zu Dual-Boot-2-Systemen?
Ja, mach so wie ich.
windows hier linux da so musste das machen guckt da wenn wir mit bmw windows linux windows linux
linux windows das ist eine vm unter der haube aber eine vm mit 8 cpu kern und 64 gigabyte ram
Die flutscht.
Sobald du allerdings
natürlich irgendwie GPU-beschleunigte
Sachen brauchst, kannst du es vergessen.
In der VM.
So.
Wir wollten eigentlich, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
ich wollte eigentlich mal Windows verschlüsseln.
So, Firefox öffnen.
Vera Crypt Download.
Dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob der ganze
Krempel jetzt... Hallo Firefox, please starten.
windows hallo
ok
linux in der vm oder windows läuft in der vm browser stabil lese ja aber youtube würde ich
tatsächlich auf dem haus gucken weil youtube möchtest du in der regel ja
hardware beschleunigt das video decoding haben also wenn ordentliche cpu es geht
das auch in der vm als kann ohne probleme hier zeigt ihr das einfach mal
ja ich gehe mal hier auf meinen youtube channel
Was ist das?
Von wann ist denn das Video? Sieht man das irgendwo?
so ich kann hier ohne probleme in der vm 1440p gucken des funds aber das problem
ist wir müssen es mal hier oben siehst du meine cpu auslastung
guck ich habe halt hier eine cpu auslastung
hessener werbung da ist ich habe eine cpu auslastung von 50 prozent oder von 30 40 prozent
also das geht schon schön ist es nicht also youtube würde ich auf dem haus gucken weil
er hat der hardware beschleunigung ja und wenn virtualisierung ab mache ich so windows auf dem
haus und linux in der vm weil sich linux unter windows viel einfacher
virtualisieren lässt als windows unter linux also gerade wenn du so sachen wie
wenn du dann so sachen nicht mit rumschlagen muss wie was den leuten
immer im chat schreiben wenn ich das sage gpu durchreichen und so was ja ja
das funktioniert dann hast du andere probleme
das ist problem dass beispiel zweiten zweiten monitor brauchst oder die
irgendwie mit Looking Glass das rüber spiegeln
musst und sowas, das macht es dann komplizierter.
Oder
eventuell musst du sogar noch eine Mouse-Path
machen, weil das ist nicht...
Es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so ganz
trivial, Windows
unter Linux ordentlich zu
virtualisieren.
Aber
Linux in der VM unter Windows
funktioniert wunderbar.
Was ist das für eine CPU?
das ist ein intel core i9 13.900 k
also high end cpu von 2022 man muss sich mal überlegen mein neuer rechner in anführungszeichen
ist schon wieder fast drei Jahre alt.
Kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen.
Und er ist immer noch
top aktuell High End.
Mit einer 4090
und 13900K nach drei Jahren.
Du hast nach drei Jahren immer noch
einen High End PC.
Jetzt muss man sich mal vorstellen, das ist eigentlich der Witz, oder?
Früher konntest du das Ding nach drei Jahren
in die Mülltonne kloppen.
Hast du schon mal auf Linux gezockt?
Ja, hab ich.
Wir haben sogar im Stream zusammen mal auf so einem Mini-PC Linux installiert und da ein paar Sachen ausprobiert.
Wir haben es sogar im Stream zusammen gemacht.
Doch, doch, habe ich.
Und man muss sagen, dass Spielen unter Linux ja mittlerweile zu 80% ganz gut funktioniert.
Aber manche Sachen hast du halt immer noch gelitten.
Beispielsweise Spiel Battlefield 6 unter Linux kannst du vergessen.
ja also antik ist das 1 er nennt es nicht das einzige aber antik ist eines
der großen probleme wo du gelitten hast aktuell noch mal gucken ob sich das
vielleicht nächsten 55 jahren oder so vielleicht noch ein bisschen ändert
und wurde natürlich auch manchmal probleme haben kannst ist spiel kommt
raus willst spielen und aus irgendwelchen gründen funzt nicht
richtig wobei man da auch der fernseh halber sagen muss das ist ja unter
windows bei vielen spielen auch gar nicht mal anders
also viele viele spiele die kommen raus und sind unspielbar guckt euch das neue
borderlands an entweder performance technik oder durch irgendwelche bugs
aber so dieses man kauft es installiert und du kannst dir relativ sicher sein es geht das
hast du halt unter linux nicht hast du unter windows aber schon der linux wird
so 80 prozent ja tut auch neue sachen aber ganz so sicher wie unter windows
kannst du da noch nicht sein und bei anti cheat ist halt eh vorbei
so ich wollte mein windows verschlüsseln
habe ich jetzt runtergeladen oder nicht wir haben ja gar nicht
unter klar okay also vera krypt x86
1 26 24 ich habe meine version ist noch viel älter die ich drauf
habe aber macht jetzt gleich das neueste englisch except install
ja mach mal und firefox darf das firefox übrigens schließen by the way donate jetzt nicht kein
tutorial alles klar so als entkripten wir mal unser windows und gucken ob das jetzt
funktioniert mit 25 h 2 system encrypt system partition drive yes type of system encryption
kann man auch noch was anderes machen
ne
Encrypt System
Encrypt Windows
Hull Drive geht nicht, weil
GPT partitioniert ist, glaube ich
Encrypt Windows Partition
Single Boot
AES
Bla bla bla, das ist okay
Passwort, massive geheimes Passwort
Daniel, danke schön für den Sub
Verschlüsselung auf Vmd, das geht
Das ist recht zackig gewesen
Das letzte Mal, das ich aufgehört habe
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, super kompliziertes
Windows Sound
Yes
So Leute
Randomness muss generiert werden
Also wenn ihr euch fragt
Wo die Randomness herkommt, ich generiere die gerade
Ich mache nochmal ein bisschen länger, dass ihr auch noch genug Randomness habt
Okay, reicht jetzt.
Next.
Ja, es ist nett von euch.
Rescue Disc.
Ich will das eh nicht
restauren.
Kann man das nicht skippen?
Kann man das nicht mehr skippen mit der Rescue-Disc?
Das letzte Mal konnte man das noch skippen.
Ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst, oder?
Habe ich den Knopf zum Skippen nicht gefunden?
das letzte mal kommt man das noch
jetzt bekommt man das ausgibt ich dann gerne hier ich für euch noch ein bisschen random das jetzt
achtung ich gerne ich gehe ich gerne wie euch noch ein bisschen redet
Ah!
Da ist der Knopf.
Okay.
Okay, Reboot.
Yes!
Randomness wurde generiert.
Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
massive passwort haben so viele leute das passwort das kann nicht schlecht sein
verbreitete sachen sind ja bekanntlichermaßen immer gut
funktioniert so als kann er die restlichen teil der disc entdeckt haben
wir mal gespannt auf funktioniert aber diesen mist ja eigentlich ausmachen
Quid.
Encrypt.
Yes.
Oh, es hängt.
Das ist aber normal. Das hatten wir das letzte Mal auch.
Das hängt immer ein bisschen.
Ich glaube, das liegt am Windows Defender.
Der Windows Defender muss ja gerade zweimal Windows Defenden.
Der Windows Defender
Defendet einmal in der VM
und einmal auf dem Haus.
Deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich auch so lahm.
Double Defender.
Ich habe übrigens was Neues gehört.
Ob bei mir auf der Arbeit.
Die haben allen Ernstes vor, Windows Defender jetzt auch auf Linux-Kisten zu installieren.
Defender kann keine VMs.
Ja, aber der Defender wird doch irgendwelche Sachen untersuchen, die auf die Disk geschrieben werden, oder?
Das ist übrigens eine sehr blöde Idee, mit dem Windows Defender unter Linux.
beim letzten Arbeitgeber, hatten wir Windows Defender auf Linux.
Und das war Massive Pains Champ.
Massive Pains Champ.
Also eines der Punkte, ich habe jetzt nicht mehr alles im Kopf,
aber eines der Punkte, die wirklich super eklig waren,
ja, das funktioniert.
Eine Sache, die super eklig war,
Microsoft hat Windows Defender Updates
quasi in den Virensignaturen Updates gemacht.
Also du hast nicht nur Virensignaturen bekommen,
die übrigens nur von irgendeinem komischen Microsoft-Server ging,
sondern du hast auch Programm-Updates bekommen mit den Virensignaturen.
Das war so ein Bundle.
Und auf einmal haben dann nachts irgendwie die Datenbanken hohe CPU-Auslastungen gehabt
und keiner wusste warum.
Ja, Windows Defender Update.
Die mussten dann für Oracle, kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
die mussten für Oracle ewig lange Datei-Exclude-Listen pflegen für Windows Defender.
Bei dieser Version dann.
Also das war schon eklig.
Ich habe eine Liste auf der Arbeit geschrieben und mal den richtigen Leuten zukommen lassen,
dass ich kein Fan von Windows Defender auf Linux bin,
aber ich vermute mal, das wird keinen wirklich interessieren, was ich dazu sage.
Was eigentlich blöd ist, ne?
Weil selbstverständlich, wenn sie auf einen hören müssten, dann natürlich auf mich, auch sonst keinen, logischerweise.
Ne, aber da wird wahrscheinlich keiner drauf hören.
Wenn ich sage, ich will keinen Windows Defender auf meinen Linux-Kisten haben.
aus den und den Gründen. Das können die besten
Gründe ever sein. Das wird keinen interessieren.
Ah ja, gut. Wären das encrypted?
Wisst ihr, wo das...
Ich wollte euch ja noch was anderes erzählen.
Wisst ihr, wo das erste Mal, wo ich das
erste Mal in meinem Leben gehofft habe,
dass die ganzen kleinen
Einzelhandelsläden irgendwann untergehen werden und ich hoffentlich alles nur noch in nächster
Zeit, ich wusste damals nicht mal, dass es das Internet gibt, im Internet, also ich habe mir
damals gedacht, so ein Versand für Elektronik-Sachen wäre doch richtig nice, irgendwas, was funktioniert
und man sich nicht mit nervigen Verkäufern rumschlagen muss und das habe ich mir das erste
mal gedacht da war ich das mal kurz moment wo ich muss nachkommen das war 1995 kam ja war nicht auch
1995 raus der kennede einen zusammenhang aber es war 1995 1995 war ich elf ich bin 1984 geboren ist
du hast 1 ich war 11 1995 und zwar wollte ich mir 1995 während das ein kryptiker konzernierungskiste
ich wollte mir 1995 secret of evermore kaufen kennt das jemand noch von euch das super nintendo
spiel gewesen im nachhinein betrachten wo ich sagen ein irgendwie sonderlich geiles super
Finde so, ich fand das gar nicht so geil.
Was mir überhaupt nicht daran gefallen hat, ist, dass es keinen Soundtrack in dem Sinne hatte.
Es hatte kaum Musik.
Ich fand es damals auch geil, aber im Nachhinein betrachtet, fand ich das dann doch wieder gar nicht so gut.
Zumindest wollte ich für Secret of Evermore kaufen.
Und damals, um Super Nintendo Spiele zu kaufen, musste man noch in ein Geschäft fahren.
So, und es war immer ein absoluter Krampf, Super Nintendo Spiele zu bekommen bei uns.
Da ist man damals, ist man in Kaufhof gefahren oder in Hertie oder was es da nicht alles für Läden gab.
Und wir hatten bei uns im Ort damals so einen kleinen Elektronikladen, der auch Super Nintendo Spiele hat.
Und ich wollte das halt haben, so 1995 irgendwann, als es rausgekommen ist.
oder falls es in,
wann ist es in Europa rausgekommen?
1996, ja.
1996 in Europa ist es rausgekommen.
Okay, war ich zwölf? Nee, nee, war ich immer noch elf.
Zumindest
bin ich in diesen kleinen Elektronikladen
gegangen und hab
gesagt, ich hab
nen Super Nintendo
und ich
hätte gerne Secret of Evermore.
Kannte sie nicht.
Ging schon gut los.
Ging schon gut los. Hab ich gesagt, ja, das ist
Der kleine Max steht da halt im Lahn, ja das ist ein super Nintendo Spiel, das ist jetzt neu.
Ja, ich guck mal nach.
Und da hatte ich es dann irgendwie gefunden und da kam halt das übliche, was in solchen Läden immer kommt, haben wir nicht da.
Können wir aber bestellen.
Hab ich gesagt, gut, dann bestellen wir das.
Und das hat mich schon abgefuckt, dass man das Spiel bestellen musste.
Ihr wisst ja wie das ist, wenn du was haben willst, willst du es gleich haben.
und, okay, bestellung, wann ist es denn da, ungefähr, ja, ungefähr zwei Wochen,
da muss ich schon mal kecken, Alter, was, zwei Wochen, Alter, ist das jetzt irgendwie,
muss das noch frisch gepresst werden für mich, oder wie,
ja, aber gut, dir ist nichts anderes übrig geblieben, wie der Chat sagt,
du warst ja früher darauf angewiesen, und jetzt folgt, glaube ich,
die längste Odyssee, die ich je hatte für ein Spiel,
Ich bin dann nach zwei Wochen hingegangen und da hieß es, es ist immer noch nicht da.
Es gibt so wenig Exemplare irgendwie in Europa, das ist noch nicht da und wir kriegen das dann.
Wann soll ich wiederkommen? Ja, nächste Woche.
Nächste Woche wiedergekommen, war immer noch nicht da.
Und ich war keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht mehr, wie oft ich in dem Laden war.
Bestimmt, boah, 20 Mal oder so.
Das heißt, ich habe dann im Endeffekt 20 Wochen oder so drauf gewartet, irgendwie ein paar Monate.
bis das Spiel da war.
Und ich habe jedes Mal diesen Kackladen
und alles verflucht, was damit zu tun hatte,
wo ich mir gedacht habe,
Alter, warum bin ich auf diese kleinen Scheiß-Drecksläden angewiesen?
Warum kann man nicht einfach das kaufen, was man kaufen will?
Man gibt doch Geld dafür aus.
Das war das erste Mal, wo ich mir,
obwohl ich es nicht wusste,
gewünscht habe, dass es Amazon gibt.
Mit zwölf Jahren hat noch kein Mensch an Amazon gedacht.
Das war 1995, 1996.
96 aber ich habe mir damals gewünscht dass es amazon gibt ohne zu wissen dass es amazon ist
Versand damals war so was wie quelle otto und neckermann dann die die oma es haben immer mit katalog bestellt
Wenn wenn er heute jemanden katalog in die hand drückt
Ja drückt man in einem super katalog in die hand der weiß überhaupt nicht was du vor die bild
mit zwölf hätt ich ein Startup gründen sollen. Das sagt mir nichts. Oh je, ich glaube es ist fertig.
Es hat mit Artefakten Sound gebimmelt.
Okay
So, jetzt gucken wir, ob
Reboot funktioniert
Dann weiß ich auch, dass
Veracrypt mit 25 H2 funzt
Was aber cool damals war
Und das ist eine Sache
Die
vermisse ich nicht wirklich, aber
die war nice.
Und zwar
zu den Zeiten habe ich mir halt auch
Gaming-Zeitschriften gekauft,
so GameStar und sowas.
Kann mich noch an den StarCraft-Tests
in der GameStar oder den Half-Life-Tests
erinnern, 97 oder so in der GameStar.
Ja, funktioniert, nice.
Und
damals hatten die Gaming-Zeitschriften
und allgemein die ganzen
PC-Zeitschriften, die hatten immer eine CD dabei.
später war es dann wahrscheinlich mal eine DVD.
Aber ich habe mich immer richtig auf die GameStar gefreut,
die kam ja einmal im Monat raus,
damit ich die Sachen auf der CD ausprobieren konnte.
Damals waren hier nicht nur Demos, Demos, ja,
da waren aber auch Patches für Spiele drauf.
Du konntest dir damals nicht einfach mal einen 600 MB Patch runterladen oder sowas.
Und es gab, also gerade Half-Life, Half-Life 1,
Half-Life 1 hat so viele Updates bekommen
und hatte auch so viele Mods und sowas.
Da hast du dich kaputt geladen mit einem Modem.
Später mit ISDN und dann irgendwann auch mit DSL.
Siedler 2, Siedler 2, mega gut.
Übrigens, es gibt ein freies Open Source Siedler 2.
Falls das jemand mal irgendwann spielen möchte.
Es gibt ein Siedler 2 Open Source.
wie hieß das nochmal das meine ich nicht ich hieß das denn siegler 25 genau dass er
das meine ich
da kann man sieht da kann man sieht zwei spielen
Webseite sieht aus wie 1925.
Ja.
Das ist mal ein nice Game.
Naja.
Aber so sah es damals mit den Läden aus.
Und, und...
Es gab halt auf den GameStar CDs, hast du halt Patches für aktuelle Spiele gehabt.
Und manchmal gab es dann halt auch so die besten Half-Life-Mods und sowas.
Da hat sie dann auf einer CD
also drauf
Counter-Strike
ähm, boah, was gab's denn
damals noch alles?
Deathmatch-Maps
ähm, wie hieß
dieser Counter-Strike für Schnitt?
Für Unreal Tournament nochmal, da gab's
auch sowas. Ähm,
Sven,
Seven oder Sven Coop, wie hieß das Ding?
Half-Life, eins von beiden.
Ähm,
Team Fortress,
Und so Zeug.
War damals dann halt auf so CDs drauf.
Da hast du halt dann irgendwie ein paar Gigabyte,
oder Gigabyte wär jetzt nicht gewesen sein auf einer CD,
aber ein paar hundert MB Half-Life-Mods und Patches drauf gehabt.
Richtig nice.
Ich hab mich fast mehr auf die CD damals gefreut,
wie auf die Zeitung selbst.
Asvenko-Op hieß es, nicht Seven.
Ja, mach ich.
Und ich würde auch gerne Battlefield 6 spielen.
Aber dazu brauche ich erstmal eine neue Windows Installation auf meiner neuen SSD, deswegen
haben wir das heute auch ausprobiert, mit Secure Boot an.
Das passt ganz gut, weil mein Windows läuft ja auch ab, supporttechnisch.
Ich habe noch 23H2 und 24H2 will sich nicht installieren lassen, deswegen installiere
ich jetzt auf einer neuen SSD Windows 25H2 mit Secure Boot und allem und dann auch Battlefield
Chat jetzt wo ich euch das erzählt haben könnt ihr könnt ihr meinen hass auf so kleine elektronik leben irgendwie nachvollziehen
also ich habe mir damals echt in amazon gewünscht ohne dass ich wusste dass es halt amazon vergeben wird
5 bis 10 Debugging Streams?
Du meinst weil das mit Secure Boot nicht funktioniert?
Doch ich denke das funzt.
Die können auch nichts dafür.
Doch.
Die können was dafür.
Also ich meine, wenn die Leute im...
Also jetzt wegen dem Spiel jetzt nicht.
Da können die tatsächlich wahrscheinlich nicht so viel dafür.
Aber mit der Geschichte, die ich vorhin mit dem Phobis erzählt habe und sowas,
da können die schon was dafür.
Aber heute ist das anders.
Heute kriegst du Spiele bei Amazon auch zum Release.
Ich weiß noch, wie ich mit dem Fabian zusammen immer bei Spielekrotte bestellt habe.
Spielekrotte, die haben die CDs und die DVDs früher losgeschickt, sodass die teilweise schon das Wochenende davor da waren.
Ja, das ist genau wegen solchen Dingern.
Du brauchst irgendwas.
Im Laden oftmals ein Riesenakt, weil du irgendeinen Typ dastehen hast, der keine Ahnung hat, was du willst.
Vorhin habe ich auch erzählt.
Ich war gestern im Bauhaus und habe mir eine Rohrbelüfter gekauft.
Rohrbelüftung, Rohrbelüfter, wie auch immer.
So ein kleines Ding zum Zwischenschrauben, ja.
Und er meinte zu mir noch, ach, gibt eh nur eine Größe.
Und was ist, passt bei mir nicht.
Ich habe einen M27 Wasserhahn und das ist ein M28 Rohrlüfter.
Rohrbelüftung, Rohrlüfter, wie auch immer.
genau das teil heißt von wegen es gibt nur eine größe früher gab es amazon noch nicht
und wegen so viel negativen erfahrungen jetzt gar nicht wegen dem super nintendo
spiel da können die wirklich nicht viel für kann ich echt ich
ganzer einzelhandelslehnen ich bestelle alles nur noch online
Ja, Chat, Funst,
vor allem,
wo ich ein bisschen verwirrt bin, ist,
warum ist meine Festplatte
auf einmal jetzt so voll? Ich hatte
150 MB, Chat,
das checke ich jetzt nicht.
Guckt mal,
ich hatte 100, ich hatte
150 MB frei und
Meine Festplatte hier ist nur...
Achso, vielleicht wegen den Snapshots.
System 3. Hä?
Wartet mal, ich lösche mal kurz die Snapshots.
Löschen wir mal die Snapshots. Delete. Yes.
Gucken wir mal zu, was die...
Okay, es wird ein bisschen was frei.
Alter!
Die Snapshots sind ja hyperfett.
Äh
Jetzt wird es wieder weniger
Okay
Was auch immer
Äh
Ich dachte
Snapshot löschen sorgt dafür, dass man
Mehr Platz bekommt
Und ich
Crash halt nicht immer YouTube
Da müssen wir jetzt hin
Brauchst wieder mehr Platz.
Ich lösche jetzt mal die VM.
Und danach gucken wir mal, ob ich so viel Platz habe wie vorher.
Weil wenn nicht, weiß ich echt nicht, woran das liegt.
Also Cleaning up Snapshots braucht Speicherplatz.
Ist auch nice.
Guck.
Was auch immer.
Cleaning up.
So sieht Aufräumen aus, Leute.
Festplatte wird immer voller.
Nicer Cleanup.
Was ich mache,
ich lösche gerade Snapshots von meiner VM
und wundere mich, warum die Festplatte immer voller wird
beim Snapshot löschen.
Was ist denn das? Die ist ja gleich voll.
vom Snapshot löschen.
What the fuck?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Seriously?
Uploadcom!
Das ist doch jetzt ein Witz, oder?
What the fuck, Alter?
Die Platte ist gleich voll.
WTF, was passiert hier?
Ist 990...
990 pro QLC.
Äh, keine Ahnung.
Das sind aber die schnellen Dinger.
Ey.
Wollen die mich ernsthaft verarschen?
Meine fucking Festplatte ist gleich voll.
Vom Snapshot löschen.
WTF?
Ah, jetzt haben wir wieder Platz.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir wieder 78.
78 Gig.
Okay.
Was ist das für ein richtiger Pepega-Krave?
Power off.
So.
Okay.
Dann öffnen wir mal hier das VM-Directory.
Löschen, löschen.
Keg Windows wird gelöscht.
Oh, Margie gibt es auch noch.
Gehen wir mal in den Papierkorb und schmeißen es weg.
Yes.
Und jetzt haben wir wieder, wie viel Platz?
Ah, jetzt haben wir, okay, jetzt haben wir fast das gleiche wieder wie vorher.
Okay, immerhin.
Windows ME, Ludl.
also chat das mit windows und lokalem user ging ja super easy ich habe keine ahnung warum die
sich auf reddit alle so beschweren macht sinn macht sinn aber warum wird dann erst was frei
und auf einmal doppelt so viel voll das macht doch eigentlich keinen sinn
Naja wobei
wobei wenn ich mir das jetzt ernsthaft überlege macht das doch sinn
du kannst ja wahrscheinlich nicht an jedem beliebigen punkt anfangen da irgendwie rüber zu schreiben
trotzdem kacke dass die festplatte vorlaufen kann vom snapshot löschen
ab 25 hat zwei ist es schwieriger geworden mit lokalem user aber
anscheinend für windows für windows professional nicht
professional
so hier mal unsere linux kiste rein
chat gibt es noch irgendwas wichtiges da auch stream heute kein dog stream wobei ich ja irgendwie
schon mal wieder Bock hätte
auf eine Runde eben.
Nämlich jetzt, solange ich mal eingeloggt war.
Mein Blackthorn ist ja mehr oder weniger
irgendwie schon dead.
Muss ich mal gucken. Mal gucken, was
heute Abend am Start ist.
Bisschen sinnlos BG sticken
oder so.
Also mit wenn du windows 11 professional hast kannst du einfach sagen ich will es in der domäne erden
Und das dann nie machen dann kannst du auch lokalen user anlegen
Hast du schon heim automatisierung mit der mülltonne gesehen was
was neben wie wo
Spiel...
Ach, still.
Oh, da habe ich ganz lang keine Videos mehr von gesehen.
Den habe ich doch immer gerne geguckt hier.
Spiel und Zeug.
Aber das gucken wir uns dann morgen an.
Ich wurde über den Tisch gezogen.
Unsere Seele fliegt immer glatt.
Manche Gewerke aber noch weniger.
Okay.
hat er probleme mit handwerkern
wo ist das mit der mülltonne
tonne
Welches welches video das da
euer
acht der hat wieder wurde die wurde von den usern die dinger zeigt ja das habe ich immer gerne geguckt
youtube hat mir das schon ewig nicht mehr empfohlen alter
Dabei würde ich es auch gerne weitergucken.
Das gucken wir nicht jetzt, das gucken wir morgen.
Ich bin jetzt fertig für heute.
Hat alles gut funktioniert.
Chat, wir können jetzt abstimmen, was wir im nächsten Stream machen.
Nee, nee, vergesst, das ist eine schlechte Idee.
Das ist eine schlechte Idee, weil ich kenne mich.
Wenn dann der nächste Stream ist, habe ich keinen Bock,
das zu machen, was wir heute abgestimmt haben.
Nee, wir stimmen nicht ab.
So, aber die Kiste war aus hier.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Was hältst du von der Idee von einem Server-Bastel-Stream?
Hast ja gesagt, dass du nur Nextcloud nutzt, weil noch dein...
Oh, da heu mal bloß auf.
brauche ich nicht ich brauche keinen kollabor und sowas und server basteln was soll ich da
basteln ich habe hier meine kiste die läuft und die fasse ich auch nicht an
da gibt es glaube ich nicht viel was wir basteln können und raspberry pi ist naja
meine zwecke meistens nicht so nice
Ihr lernt in der Fachhochschule immer noch VBA.
Ist VBA nicht immer noch angesagt, wenn es um Scripting für Office-Anwendungen geht?
Eieia
Oder gibt es da was anderes mittlerweile
Wie skriptet man Office Sachen wenn es nicht VBA ist
Excel Datenbanken
Ja
Ich sag ja Excel ist die IDE der Sekretärin
Echt man skriptet mit Python Office Sachen
Was Microsoft nicht alles macht hier
Tatsächlich.
Nicht schlecht.
Exes.
Also von Exes verstehe ich die Daseinsberechtigung nicht.
Ich habe ernsthaft keine Ahnung,
was die Existenzberechtigung von MS-Exes ist.
Hast du noch Kontakt zu Leuten von German Taters?
Nee.
So Leute, schön, dass ihr am Start wart.
Gucken, ob es morgen früh Aufwachen-Streamen gibt.
Ich gehe jetzt off.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
CU